just have a few moments
thank you for to remain standing for the
council prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance
wisdom and judgment as we face the tasks
before
us and enable us now and always to
readily discharge
the trash trust placed by the people in
our hands
i mean
just a reminder everyone that's we're
live streaming so
just be aware of that
and we've got zoom attendees
there's no zoom attendance attendees
here tonight
no there are none no no
apologies
and public forum
interest register any changes
seem to have two
minutes of the meeting out of risk
insurance committee
22nd of march move those uh received
your worship
stinging in moved and seconded any
discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye
minutes of the meeting of council held
on the 23rd of march
move those who worship second moved in
second
any discussion questions put
[Music]
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
infrastructural
services committee held on the 29th of
march
i'll move those be received your worship
and at the same time i would like to
also move that council adopts
item 7.1 and 7.2 which are the
roading and traffic bylaw review and the
parking control by law review at the
same time
i would second those it's moved and
seconded any questions
discussion the suitor is here if there
are any issues relating to the bylaw
report
are there any issues
thank you you worship no just only to
note that we have
um made a few minor administrative
administrative amendments to fix a few
dates that were incorrect in the by-laws
they will come into force
on first of july and we have also
removed section
21 which related to occupation of
vehicles on
roads as it's been raised to our
awareness that was not an alignment so
just to update you all on that
thank you any questions
do you have a mover in a second yes you
do uh
councillor pottinger and councillor
thank you move and it counselor patenter
and counselor lewis
fear the questions discussion put it to
the vote all in favor say
aye aye carried
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
the performance
policy and partnerships committee
held on the 29th of march move that
those who received your worship
second did you worship moved and
seconded any discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye
aye against carried
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
council held on the 29th
of march again on my face
second though is your worship moved and
seconded discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say
aye aye carried minutes of the meeting
of the infrastructural services
committee held on the seventh of april
i will move those you worship sir moved
and seconded
any discussion questions put it to the
vote all in favor say
aye against carried
in the recommendation we have follows
to the council who's leading us
on that one i think it's explanatory
worship
uh i can move that your worship it's the
uh q park reserve classification
i'll second that your worship moved and
seconded any questions
discussion put it to the vote all in
favor say
aye aye against carried
and we moved down to the minutes of the
meeting of performance policy and
partnerships committee held on the
thirteenth of april
if they received your worship second
moved and seconded
any discussion questions put it to the
vote or in favor say
aye aye it's carried
when it's at the meeting oh sorry
minutes of the meeting of the bluff
community board held on the 19th of
april
i'll move that we receive those you
worship i second that your worship
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carried
[Music]
and traffic and parking bylaws
we adopted them under a previous
resolution
any discussion questions
okay moving on to the
working and we're on working
together update from project governance
group
where are we going with that
do your worship i'm happy to speak to
the report
the title um
update report is a bit of a misnomer
really because this report
presents for council's consideration
two of the foundation documents that the
working groups and the
pgg have been working on over the last
period of time
those documents give effect to
richard thompson's recommendations at
least some of them including
some of those that the council itself
adopted in november last year
so there are a suite of resolutions
dealing with
the endorsement of an mou between
yourself
and deputy mayor clark which i can
advise the meeting has been signed
there's a resolution dealing with
professional development opportunities
for councillors
and then there's the council charter
there are also some matters for the
council to note
with uh your leave your worship can i
recommend that we deal with item seven
first that being the endorsement of the
council charter
the document's been sometime in the
making and it sets out a
suite of guiding principles that are
relevant to
today's decision making and to our
collective conduct
into the future jeff and i have
canvassed
counselors supporter otherwise for the
charter and
pleased to advise that all members of
council including yourself your worship
have indicated to us that they are
prepared to vote to adopt the charter
and to sign it as a signal of their and
your individual
and collective commitment to its
principles
thank you your wish
there's a discussion questions
you worship i'm happy to move um that
item seven is endorsed happy to see him
that your worship
it's moved and secreted item seven
discussion questions put it to the
battle and favor say aye
hi against carriage so
are you going to stop and sign it now
all right so
others to come up
if you like to come forward counselors
why not your time
i want my pen bag
thank you
right
hi
what's your rejection
excellent
um
can i suggest that you uh put the
receipt of the report then i may
uh briefly speak to the mou
which is recommendation number two so
perhaps if you could put the receipt of
the report we'll
move through i'll move that second
intuition
moved and seconded discussion
questions put it to the voucher and
purpose
thank you your worship uh councillors
you will recall
uh a specific observation
in the thompson report that
the organization would benefit from
clarification of the role of deputy
mayor
a number of approaches to defining
that role have been considered and on
balance
having worked with
the two signatories to the mou was
agreed that an mou
as opposed to a job description which
may
have other implications would be the
preferred approach
before handing back to you your worship
can i
acknowledge the contribution that my
colleague
jeff grant has made to getting this
agreement
through and to you both for the
i guess approach and in some respects
the concessions that
you have both made to get an arrangement
in place
which will serve the future
organization well assuming of course
that there is a binding commitment
to give effect to the obligations
that it contains thank you your worship
thank you your worship i'm happy to move
recommendation too
that council endorses the memorandum
of understanding but with the addition
that the chief executive take the
necessary steps to support the deputy
mayor
in supporting the mayor and representing
the city
i'll second that nation moved and
seconded
further questions discussion
i'd be happy to move recommendations
three
two six is a block your worship
okay we're second to potential second
question
any questions discussion can i just add
do we need to also
include item number one the working on
working together report receiving it
we've done that oh we've done that
discussion further discussion questions
put it to the bottom favor say aye aye
aye aye aye
you wish can i make one other
observation before we move off the
item and that really relates to page 125
of the agenda
where we note reasonably cryptically
that the commitment that you have
recently all made to the charter has
already been tested somewhat
and that is in relation to
concerns that exist within the
organization in relation to
an odt story that quoted
you sir in relation to the i.t support
that you were receiving
councils will know that the chairs group
was sufficiently concerned about that
to seek retraction and a correction from
yourself
uh your worship and we were advised
uh today that that
retraction and apology wouldn't be
forthcoming
at that point um i leave the matter
as it is for counsellors rather than an
external advisor
to determine whether or not any other
action
is taken thank you
anthony thanks your worship um i'd
actually like to speak to that item and
move
emotion uh in regards to it but i'm just
wondering whether
it uh is appropriate that you are
cheering this part of the meeting and
whether
somebody else should be cheering
this that was a matter that was raised
oh that matter was raised at the cheers
meeting
yeah i would move that we uh out of um
any risk of conflict that we do
um and state a new chair for this item
i'll second that motion
respectfully might i suggest that this
matter would
probably sit under ppp and that might be
best
positioned for councillor ludlow to take
the reins
i would check in that
repeat the discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
it's carried thank you but you leave
your worship i'll remain
down here councillor amundsen
thanks councillor ludlow i think that
mr mckenzie has raised a really good
point about the article that appeared in
the odt on the 9th
of april regarding the technology
training
that the mir believes he did not receive
or was denied
and at the time when that was raised
with chairs we indicated to the mayor
that
this information was inaccurate and we
asked him to retract it which he did not
do
and the article subsequent subsequently
was published
we also have subsequently asked for a
public apology
regarding that article because we
believe it paints the council in a bad
light
and as has been mentioned that was
declined
so the motion that i would like to put
forward in regards to this is that the
council
records its concern about the factually
incorrect statements has worshipped the
mayor made in the odt on friday the 9th
of april 2021
where he claimed that he had been denied
one-on-one training
i.t training by council and secondly
the council records its disappointment
that he has failed to correct the facts
and to apologize in an equivalent public
forum
for the harm caused to the organisation
as requested by the chairs group
thank you we have a motion i'm looking
for a seconder i'll second that
is there any way we can get that motion
up on the board it's rather
long
yes we will get that on the screen for
you
it's open for discussion councillor
pottinger
um look it's it's
very accurate what um councillor munson
has said
i actually see it personally as
firstly a breach of the code of conduct
um i spoke up
against the media protocol
purely because i thought the code of
conduct had it covered
section 6.2 of our code of
conduct the last item there refers
specifically to media comments
and it states media comments must not be
misleading
and should be accurate within the bounds
of reasonableness
now um
i did not seek a code of conduct
procedure uh to be put in motion because
we've been there we've done that it
costs a lot of money
and this is what we've talked about at
the cheers group
and i think uh what council romansen has
raised
just makes us aware that we
need to be in this working together
as a group and obey by the rules it
doesn't gag anyone
it just means that when you speak you
actually speak
factually correct so that's my
uh take on the situation thank you
councillor clark
yes i just wanted to reiterate what
councilor potten just said
i was at the chairs meeting when this
was raised a couple of weeks ago three
weeks ago
um and i found it really difficult um
the mayor stated at that meeting that he
was taking a different tact with the uh
with the media and was going to be on
the front foot and his colleagues
were a bit upset by the fact that uh
what he was saying about the
one-on-one it training was incorrect
um and challenged him about whether that
change of tact
and freedom of speech gave him the
opportunity to
be telling something less than the truth
and um
and his response was well i've got
greater mana in the community than any
of us will ever have
and it was frustrating because the last
three or four or five media
comments we've had in the last three or
four weeks i've all been negative of
counsel
and most of them have been unjustified
so i think going forward we need to have
a
more of a collective agreement that will
um will be positive about what we're
doing
and not negative and what has come up as
part of this debate about the
request for an apology was whether the
mayor had it in fact
actually had in the it training and i
can clarify for the
for this meeting that i gave the mayor
and his partner two and a half hours of
training on
diligent books it was a method that was
very easy for
anybody to encompass and it was spelled
out very easily
and so to be told in the media that it
hadn't been
was not only a reflection on council and
council staff who also helped in that
but it was also a reflection on the work
that i've done as well
so i support the motion that's put
thank you any other speakers councillor
soper then councillor abbott then
councillor scout
i'll leave the others up because since i
was the second year old okay thank you
councillor abbott well i'll be led by
you and your advice in the ce
um but i am asking whether the mayor is
going to respond
whether he retaliates or
and is he allowed to yes
because i'd like to hear his side of the
story and the reason i say that
is that um with respect the committee
that have formulated this
this discussion today and it has been
formulated has been
almost orchestrated um we as
fellow councillors who are out of that
umbrella uh
it's a bit of a surprise policy i don't
like surprises it was said before that
we would never surprise each other i
think that might even be in the charter
but this has come as a surprise so
with only half the facts that i'm
hearing from ian and others i want to
hear what the mayor has to say
thank you we'll come to that in just a
moment i think councillor scout wanted
to speak but these have been in the
minutes from the cheers meetings that
are circulated after each one council
because that was only today
no 12 a couple of weeks ago yeah i've
got it here
from two weeks ago thank you to you
cheer i just wonder given the
information we've had this afternoon
backing up what
council lado says the um the information
was out a couple of weeks ago
but given the information we've had
today in the cheers meeting the worship
and given the tone of the meeting now i
just wonder
if you might like to take the
opportunity now to reflect
and perhaps take this opportunity
and maybe change your mind
so that we can all move forward there
would be a really positive mood
if we could do that so i'm asking you if
you could do that
no thank you
councilors thank you councillor ludlow
um as the seconder of the motion i want
to
absolutely confirm that there was no
pre-arrangement about
about this matter today um
and i certainly want to confirm that it
was two weeks ago that this was raised
in an open report to us all
about the cheers meeting
[Music]
i'm supporting this motion because i
think that this is
an issue on which it is time
we have all just signed a an agreement
that we have all undertaken to hold to
correction and apology in an equivalent
public forum
is a reasonable request it's a standard
to which we should all hold ourselves
it's a standard to which i believe we
have just committed in the charter we
have signed
that if any of us do make these sorts of
incorrect statements
that they will be corrected and an
apology will be made
in an equivalent form that is an
exceptionally reasonable request
it's to my mind actually quite a low
standard to which we should hold
ourselves i hope that
we hold ourselves to much higher
standards but this one i think is
fundamental to this council moving on
as part of
showing the people who elected us that
we we are indeed a council who is united
and can move on
so it is very disappointing to hear
the mayor say no to a very simple and
reasonable request
i can also confirm and back up with
councillor clark
that in fact the councillor clark
undertook the one-to-one
training that councillor clarke has
mentioned i have sat
with the mayor and others in training on
our diligent board books
as many of you know because of my
shoulder injury
i was one of the last adopters of the
board books and we went
through a sender training with myself
and some of the others who had adopted
late
and the mere and to my memory set beside
me during that time
and received assistance from others
in that training so there has been an
adequate amount of training
it was upsetting to see those particular
comments in the media and i think that
this is a very reasonable request and a
reasonable way in which this has been
brought up
thank you any other speakers
if not council rabbit the motion is up
there now
uh it records uh council's uh
reaction and clarification uh if there
are no further speakers
i'll put the motion all in favor aye aye
against i'm going to abstain because i
would love to have
heard the mayor's response to be quite
frankly
you did well to a degree not the
response counselor
i think it would be helpful going
forward for the mayor to have a chance
to explain other than just to say no
i think that would be a positive thing
if we get to a final vote
if that can be facilitating it could
well be
do we want to do that now i think that
would be good i think give tim the
opportunity to speak
to the issues that have been put to him
and address what learns he's raised as
well
your worship yes thank you
um i did have a change of policy and
the past i didn't comment
on any issues that were put before me
um and it didn't work
so i decided to change my policy and
respond immediately
when the media could question me on
any issue um
and that's how i why i'm abstaining i
do want to have the opportunity and i
will be looking for it to find out
exactly what the facts are
it's a bit of a who shed
who she said
and it's
i know i was angry over the weekend too
because the battle for crete was blamed
purely on new zealanders and
that that to me seemed a very
unfair assertion especially for
international television
to take and that's why i want to make
sure
that before making a public statement
i am fully informed about
exactly what has happened
thank you worship councillor abbott so
therefore
sir tim do you acknowledge that you did
have training
all those issues will be covered
councillor clark yes uh lindsay for your
benefit i
got a record here yeah i just want an
acknowledgement from
we definitely have the training okay
it's
been uh put to the vote councillor
abbott your abstention
is noted um has it been put to the point
yes you asked to be abstained
uh that would be the end of that matter
sir i'll return you to the chair
thank you
were we up to item three
four iccm
draft chartered
i'd like to thank all the members of the
public and
media and
for your attendance yesterday
i'll move that we go into public
excluded i'll second that
okay
you